all right guys bang-bang I've got
Bradley here super excited to talk thank
you so much for uh for doing this yeah
super excited thanks for having me for
sure for those that don't know you let's
start with background where were we born
where'd you grow up and what'd you do
before role yeah so that born in New
York City grew up just outside of the
city in a small suburb called
Westchester for those familiar it's a
small one-square-mile town they're
called Ardsley went to Columbia became
pretty fascinated with venture capital
wrote a book that a lot of people read
actually called breakin 2 BC it's funny
a lot of Gen Z people read it now and
ping-mei and it's kind of how they get
there so see it analyst jobs from there
worked as a an entrepreneur in residence
at Tuck Stars and the founding Ries it
was one of the family researchers a coin
desk and my job was really putting
together these huge reports called the
state of blockchain reports after
merrymakers state of the internet
reports this was around the time that
around
you know maybe five researchers in the
space 2015-2016 aetherium blew up did a
huge report on that and really kind of
never looked back
got it and so first thing I asked about
write in the book do you self publish it
or did you go with like a publishing
house yeah as a crazy story so I won't
I won't name names but I had a
publishing deal in Canada it's a small
publishing company and they were like oh
this is great a soft skills book this
fits with you know this other guy who's
also writing a book yeah we'll publish
it in like 2021 and this was in like
2017 and I had slowly realized that I
guess writing a book and getting a deal
was very similar to like signing to a
major label or something like this where
you really don't have any right to
decision so read literally twelve books
on self-publishing had a mini launch
party on on Facebook at the time and
just launched it man and it's just it
just becomes something that a bunch of
people are reading that
pretty excited about you that's awesome
and then how'd you get the job at a coin
desk yeah it's a really good story so I
was working at a sort of an analyst
associate at a firm and this was around
2014 and we had we were we were all
assigned sectors to sort of choose and
everyone was terrified of Bitcoin so I
just dove right in and basically chose
Bitcoin as the sector I'd look I'd look
into and at that time sort of 2014 there
really wasn't any news sources there
were a few blogs and really just coin
desk so all roads really led to coin
desk at that time in the team there was
about four people on the team this is a
Ryan selcas Pete Rizzo and a few guys
running up so literally ping them had a
beer jumped on and the rest was sort of
history from there that's awesome and
had you heard of Bitcoin before you
decided to cover it or you just were
intrigued the first time you heard it
was pretty familiar sort of start
hearing about it like 2012 2013 but but
didn't was really trying to find an
excuse to to get involved and just being
the guy at a firm has always been I kind
of talk about that as an author like a
lot of folks still ping me I'm like how
do you get in the VC and you literally
just need to become the person the kind
of knows topics becoming that person for
a topic was really interesting I loved
how I would really shied away from the
idea of digital currency in 2014-2015 so
just saw an opportunity today then so
made a lot more sense for you to do it
that's awesome and so as you get to coin
- you start writing these big reports
ether and aetherium come out what was
the general sense like there's a lot of
people who know that the ICO was
relatively popular and in terms of the
build-up to but maybe kind of from your
seat at the time like what was the the
things that you remember going into the
ICO and then kind of the first couple of
months afterwards yeah I was a insane
time I mean people
and I can't name names but people were
coming to the office that had just
raised like tens of millions of dollars
or hundreds of millions of dollars at
that time they were all just really
curious about how to get covered and
coin des they wanted to be in sort of
our reports and my job also at the time
was really looking into these things
things like waves and sort of other
block chains that were we're sort of
coming out and sort of sort of seeing
what's going on it was it was I was
pretty much the Wild West you know just
kind of like watching a John Wayne movie
or something and just seeing all this
this sort of action happened you really
couldn't necessarily tell the difference
between sort of an ethereal more waves
at the time he was kind of it's kind of
pretty difficult but but eventually you
know all the smoke cleared I started
diving a little deeper after the
etherium hard for I had to write a piece
on like a theorem classic in the
differences and was just pretty
fascinated about that the dow came out
and yeah formally decided to start
building on top of a theory i'm around
2017 got it and did you always know that
you wanted to go and build a company or
was it something that as you just
learned more about the technology you
eventually said hey this is this is
something that i should go do yes that's
another insane story so so basically I
was at Coyne desk wrote the book and
effectively the book did so well that I
basically went on needed to go on a book
tour and I spoke at around 20 colleges
and because of the nature of the book
breaking into venture capital a lot of
investors just started pinging me I'm
like who the [ __ ] are you like how did
you write this book what's going on and
I got invited to a lot of panels that I
probably should've been on but jumped on
them anyway so one of those panels was
with Alex's gold as a former manager of
techstars New York he now runs a firm
called 2048 VC had dinner with him and
basically made me an entrepreneur
esident sat TechStars was the first
check-in to me as the only kind of
person with the company having sort of
grew roll from there got it and so what
when you walk in day
entrepreneur in residence at Tech
context I was like what did you want to
build does you have any idea and they
kind of how did you get from there to
here yeah
so basically phrase that by saying aye
it was just one guy goldman sachs that
yeah there's this one guy at a bank that
kind of came in to coin desk and we just
really talking about sort of the
advisory market and just sort of what
was going on in crypto and i was really
just a fly on the wall in the room and
really just thought man i could meet
this guy's launch i know most of the
people in the space i know how to raise
and all these things so the very first
idea sort of like the first few months
was pretty fascinated by the idea of
starting an advisory group and really
wanted to start the sort of consulting
firm that could sort of separate sort of
sort of the tier 1 companies from the
tier 2 companies they're kind of raising
so that was the initial impetus when I
jumped into techstars and then raised a
sort of a small round off that and
pivoted to roll got it and so what is
rolled today yeah so if I were to tell
you in 2010 that the next ten years
would basically generate hundreds of
billions of dollars in value for for
user-generated content
you know tick-tock Instagram Twitter etc
that would have been unfathomable so
that's gonna our thesis is that's gonna
repeat itself in a new way so
user-generated content is gonna jump
into the next phase user-generated
currency or what roll calls social money
so role is really a blockchain based
network that allows anyone to create
distribute now invest in trade their own
social money so these are branded
aetherium tokens we've made it literally
as simple as clicking a button to sort
of sign up there's over there's close to
200 communities on the network now
spending 10,000 people that hold social
money and yeah we're just super excited
about where things are going on the
operation
all right so let's start at the the core
the conversation which is what the hell
is social money yeah so take you back
and then back again here so the concept
of social currency let's say is around
120 years old right or social capital
this idea that every kind of individual
has this this network around them and
that network has this sort of almost
intangible value we sort of carried this
in like a philosophical sense
so what aetherium uniquely allows you to
do is turn this cultural primitive now
into a digital and financial primitive
so the network value that let's say you
have starting a podcast and sort of you
know a sub stack and having this
presence
the idea is you could effectively make
that fungible and tradable and send able
through aetherium and then for us we see
this really as a mass adoption primitive
in the future we see many people having
their own currencies so we wanted to
create a term that was super friendly
almost as friendly as ice cream to words
that people just like next to each other
and this effectively became social money
so social Mounier branded aetherium
tokens named after individuals and
communities and yeah and so would it be
fair to say that this is analogous to
like Amazon gift cards right where it's
a branded currency that can be used
within that network or is that something
that would be a little bit inaccurate
yeah so so we adopt a lot of language on
rawls if you go to role right now
social money can be earned it could be
redeemed but aetherium adds these
amazing benefits I mean first of all
social money now becomes interoperable
across systems right and yeah so there's
social money on blockchain platforms
like like you know swap the social
money's traded every day people exchange
it for different entities or collectible
so it's sent all the time on open sea
there's folks that use it on patreon and
twitch and Instagram and Twitter so the
idea of creating the
interoperable auditable system where the
value could be integrated into different
platforms is really special because all
of a sudden you're not just on the
network you become the network and
philosophically that's why people we
think are coming to role
they'd never really have their own money
and that's just the lead-in but
philosophically the cell is once you
have your own money you can create your
own rules and become the network and
it's a very new value prop that we think
is unique for the this decade so help me
understand like why do I let's say if
I'm X person running a community right
let's just say it's um I don't know say
whatever community why do I need my own
currency versus just use whether it's
fiat currency or one of the existing
cryptocurrencies yes so fiat currency is
great for social money we really see
this as complementary so a lot of people
that have an online community
effectively a lot of them really have
their own their own their own culture
with fan behavior they may even have
their own language with gifts and memes
what social money literally does is
bring economics to that digital
community or nation the community now
has its own money and its own sense of
belonging and what happens here is
social money really opens up new feature
sets right the community itself can be
traded it could exist on many platforms
while being sort of independent of all
platforms as well and it's an amazing
tool to really start incentivizing your
community right so if there's something
you want to do whether it's sort of more
subscriptions on you know YouTube or
more comments on sub stack you could
literally like a like a new web
superpower generate that type of
activity directly towards directly
towards those actions with your social
money got it and so I guess part of this
is it's less about the money and it's
more about the social component to
branding etc like the monetary policy if
you will is not the focus it's much more
around how do you use this new exchange
of value in a community to get people to
kind of stay locked in
more engaged to participate earn things
all of that type of stuff is that fair
yeah yeah so so we're on boarding
entirely new communities in this in this
sort of completely new way and you know
we've made the economics as simple as
you know Twitter has made you know
character counts right so Twitter has a
280 character max role is a 10 million
unit of social money maximum supply and
so every person that comes on role
doesn't need to do any mental math or
anything like this they'll come on and
know that they have a ten million supply
look at two million on day one and so
the rest will be released over time yeah
absolutely you're able to now sort of
send your social money across platforms
have it be spent on different products
and create different ways for it to be
aired so if I wanted to create let's say
a pump coin right and there's 10 million
pop coins that exist in the world do
they all hold whatever value I ascribe
to them is there an open market that
determines that value do kind of the
users in my community or network just
ascribe that value how does that work
yeah so first if you created pump I
think everyone would freak out in a
really good way you wouldn't be a loan
that there's a lot of people of massive
communities that have just joined roll
Fred Wilson testing it out with ABC we
just talked to ja rule sort of be doing
something with him later on and folks
like cami Russo and sort of others have
built sizable communities are unroll as
well what's very interesting is we we
basically cloned the unit swap protocol
so we have our own unit swap front-end
which allows any sort of social money to
be traded easily and what we would do
effectively if you wanted to is start
market making pom right so we've done
this enough that we could ascertain the
value of any social money in the
ballpark of you know an order of
magnitude so there's social money now
that's worth half a million dollars is
market cap or something that's worth a
few hundred thousand so once we once we
sort of do that the market is really
going to tell us the value of pom at
that point and it sort of stays that
what we've seen is as
or utility is driven towards social
money the demand for the network goes up
and that sort of increases the value of
social money so it's this idea of sort
of the community is almost a form of
cash flow and if there's more demand for
the community there's more demand for
your your social money what's like the
best way you've seen it used within a
community any examples that you can talk
about in terms of just obviously when
people hear money they think okay you're
paying for something or you're receiving
value for something but how have you
seen this specifically used in community
so you think is pretty cool yeah so
there's there's several examples so I
think one of the most popular ones that
barstool supports heard about this a few
others so there's someone on role as a
young entrepreneur and sort of a
community manager Alex mass smash and
sort of Alex raised $20,000 with his
social money named Alex so he
effectively built all of his rewards on
role built-in Network and did a formal
Kickstarter Kickstarter style crowd fund
and used Alex as a crowd funding
mechanism another engineer named Herman
did this as well so Herman raised around
$25,000 that's an extremely interesting
use case it's just kind of building our
own network and monetizing in this new
way aside for the people the people who
bought the the Alex token or the other
one what did they get in return
why would they buy Alex for example yeah
so buying Alex or Kerman effectively
gives you a stake in that person's
network and so what that means is you
now own basically a percentage of this
community and if you believe in sort of
the success of this community over time
what that could effectively lead to sort
of an overwhelming growth of what the
community means and the interesting
thing is this isn't just hide to Alex or
Kerman it's tied to the currency and
what we've seen over time is the most
successful social money it's utility
actually the
democratised so the biggest users of
Alex and Kerman aren't exactly those
individuals they're people in the
community using in the peer-to-peer way
which which is sort of fascinating so
you own a piece of this of this
community that can exist over time and
effectively increase as the demand for
the network increases yeah it's super
interesting and then I guess you were
going on about other use cases so you
have those two folks who raised money
essentially when they when they sold
this what are some of the other use
cases that you've seen yeah so there's a
lady who was the very first person to
issue on role her name's Laurel I met
her at VidCon and Laurel is a an
influencer with over you know a million
followers on tik-tok and Instagram and
YouTube has never touched Bitcoin has
never touched ether he's crazy about her
social money called tingles and there's
around a thousand tingle holders in the
world tingles is traded every day on
Eunice WAP and Laurel uses tingles to
incentivize the KPIs and matter of her
Laurel hasn't only fans she has a
patreon she has a tick top she has an
Instagram she has her own app I'm a I'm
a I'm a patron on our patreon some on
the $5.00 a month here every month I get
a certain amount of tingles for being a
patreon subscribers I get I get a few
thousand if I were to increase my tier
to $10 for $20 I'm gonna get more
tingles from Laurel for this and so what
she's effectively doing is creating a
network on top of her network with
tangles so we've seen this with
streamers we've seen this with sort of
creators so streamers are sort of
whether it's twitch or mixer or D live
or any platform the KPIs that matter to
them are basically donations and
subscriptions
so if you want to enhance those an
amazing way to do it is giving social
money cash back so streamers invented
this unroll they literally stopped the
stream and just start streaming roll and
give you know some PI Gauss or Forrester
or whoever the streamer is give some
social money back for those donations
and subscriptions so
large we're really seeing social money
act as a way to incentivize the KPIs
that really matter to you very cool and
I guess as part of this is it all
individual so far or have you seen what
I'll call organizations and companies
start to be interested as well yeah so
we're at a fascinating turning point so
some some some interesting things that
started happening a little while ago our
group started approaching us and was the
first interesting thing so there's a
group called defy Italy so their group
in Italy a meetup group and they talk
about defy and so they meant it Italia
with us and so you know if you want to
be an Italian you could hold some Italia
and gets you access to sort of all these
different things since then we're about
to make a few announcements so Ja Rule's
been a friend of the company for a while
we're pretty excited about that and
there's a few other platforms that
effectively want to be the role of their
industry so there's people that have
reached out to us from top streaming
platforms there's people that have
reached out to us they're connected to
festivals like South by Southwest and
Coachella there's people that have
reached out to us that are connected to
eSports teams and people that are
connected to sort of DJs etc and they
want to utilize the role infrastructure
the role protocol to allow their
platform to issue social money on behalf
of their users so if I run a popular DJ
platform and Fatboy Slim's on there or
DJ Jazzy Jeff or someone like that
you'll have a really simple interface
already on that platform where those
DJ's can plug in
utilize the role protocol and issue
social money on behalf of the user on
other platforms and so this is the
future of role we really see where
everything touched social in the past 20
years we think everything's kind of
touch social money in the next 20 years
yeah it's really interesting when you
start to look at kind of the comparison
so take us off my Southwest they don't
necessarily have money but they have
everything
from wristbands to passes and kind of
all of these things that essentially
give you access to events and things
like that but I can't necessarily take
my wristband and exchange it in any way
with either other attendees or people
who aren't there I'm sure there's people
who go you know when they're don't the
event they go sell it to somebody
outside so they can get into the event
or whatever huh but but but it sounds
like really what you guys are attempting
to do here is create a digital item that
has both monetary value and kind of the
economics behind it but also has the
utility that could be used for example
getting it access to an event or
attending something or getting a piece
of content or a meet-and-greet or
something like that absolutely yeah and
the opportunity is massive I mean just
to give you sort of a sense here by
default we've kind of become the PayPal
of this concept right so this idea that
this type of social money can be moved
can be created and moved anywhere
anytime to anyone all over the web the
same sort of value prop is PayPal but
first social money and that's allowed
you know substantial platforms to now
reach out to us and create a v2 of role
where we just become the social money
web infrastructure
please massive platforms and that's huge
and there's there's there's huge
incentive for entrepreneurs to do this
right to become the role of eSports the
role of events the role of you know
Fitness etc and so entrepreneurs are
reaching out to us ready to do this and
the most exciting thing is you know we
won't necessarily onboard like at South
by Southwest or a Tribeca Film Festival
or sort of a hundred thieves or you know
Fat Boy slim entrepreneurs will do that
through their platforms will literally
just be the infrastructure that allows
it to exist on the network yeah it's
super interesting you mentioned a couple
of people who are using it who are the
biggest people using it and then give me
an example of somebody you don't have to
name them who've tried this it hasn't
worked and explain why they found it
yeah so some of my favorite people using
role it's a bit niche but it's sort of
the the Digital Artist category so
there's people there's these people
making you know the whole crypto kitties
an FTE framework there's people making
you know provably scarce digital art
through that and they're creating social
money on role so my favorite was
probably this guy Jeff goes by skini is
from Madrid tattoos skulls on people's
arms and backs and he approached this
and created skull and he makes skull
based art and what happened next was
pretty fascinating so he offered his
skull based art on an open sea and skull
and what happened next is different
games and exchanges and an artist also
started accepting skull and skull just
became this peer-to-peer thing that all
of a sudden nothing to deal with this
guy who created it we started to market
make skull people now sort of traded
every day but you're seeing that as sort
of this inevitable path this
democratization of utility one person
starts it all of a sudden it's used for
many different cases that's been pretty
fascinating I love what's happening in
sort of the newsletter community there's
a lot of folks on sub stack tiny letter
difference with email subscription
services they're just dropping their
social money at the end of a newsletter
and they're dropping like 10 or 15
different lengths and you know only the
first few people can claim and it's just
sort of like Pavlovian and training for
people to sort of jump in and sort of
collect open the newsletter quickly
answer to collect social money one
category were really thinking through we
just on boarded our first one is his
athletes as a I think athletes are
interesting so we have a lot of like
founders we have a lot of Engineers but
a community members have a lot of
artistic creatives he's a wide opening
spot for athletes I think what would
naturally happen and we're seeing this
happen right now is is
people will start building platforms
that are for specific groups using
social money and the ideas role would be
that infrastructure so we think there
does exist a specific role based
platform for streamers for artists for
rappers for athletes and those are
things I think we'll kind of see built
the next few years hopefully on unrolls
infrastructure so it elaborate on that a
little bit right like where does all
this go because I think a lot of people
look and they say okay so you basically
have infrastructure built there's a
couple of people who have created a
couple being you know 200 or so people
have created these social money
currencies they're using it in a various
number of formats but they're you know
relatively small compared to the you
know the the world it's not like Kanye
West or an NBA player or anybody yet I
think that that's kind of where you guys
aspire to get to and there's a strong
argument as to being able to get there
but where do you see this let's call it
you know 10 years from now right you you
started out earlier talking about kind
of user-generated content creating all
this value that a lot of people wouldn't
have expected what does that look like
I'm the bull case for social money yeah
so at scale what you'll see is content
becoming currency and so we've created
this simple framework where people you
know kind of for the first time can now
come to a platform and create their own
currency what happens next is role just
opening up it's smart contracts right so
let's say we onboard Coachella or South
by Southwest and we have such
significant mindshare in the idea of
minting a social money for an event and
you want to mince some social money for
you know your birthday party or let's
say a zoom call it may not make sense to
have the same monetary policy that you
know Coachella has or that we currently
have one well you may just want to
create five and maybe an exclusive party
might create 15 or a thousand you know
whatever you actively be able to decide
all of these economic parameters through
other platforms those sort of integrated
you'll see like role parties right you
sort of login and kind of do it so this
is sort of the longtail right a bunch of
nannies are getting together for some
wine and you know the Hamptons they'll
create a sort of simple token for their
party to kind of engage and sort of
that'll be the end of it at scale I
think what you'll see is the most
interesting people creating completely
new economies because it philosophically
makes sense for them to own the value of
their network you could redefine
influencer marketing in this way brands
will effectively now want a piece of
someone's currency because that's the
network that the individual is saying
matters the most
that's what hundreds of thousands of
people are now holding and that's what
exists across let's say a tik-tok or
Twitter or next-generation platforms so
not only will the next generation of
social natively integrate this type of
currency but how brands communicate with
people can be changed if this network
shifts right and the paradigm becomes
about the currency over the content and
that's sort of the world which we see in
the infrastructure we're kind of kind of
building four so in that world like how
big is that right is that a hundred
billion dollar type economy that gets
built there is that a trillion dollars
is it ten million dollars like just how
do you think about scale here and
understanding that I'm basically asking
you to hit a moving target ten years out
it's almost an impossible task which is
kind of like today how do you think
about how big this can get from an
addressable markets damn one yeah so
there's two things that role is really
so role is one its its web
infrastructure it's this idea that you
know we could send palm back and forth
and you could use role web
infrastructure to send pump from twitch
to Twitter to Shopify to pizza at to the
mall and there's the underlying role
protocol really which anyone can sort of
plug Gmail could plug into your writing
create a role plug in start sending etc
so as
everything has sort of wrapped around
social if optimistically everything then
wraps around social money we're seeing
this as a potentially trillion-dollar
opportunity with multiple players and
the opportunity they are is owning
concepts right what do journalists
tokens look like how are they different
from DJ tokens or event tokens that
these types of categories are going to
be enormous and we're sort of the first
significant player seeing that vision I
don't think will be the last but we are
bringing this to market in a way that
the masses are reaching out so at a
protocol infrastructure level creating a
Coachella token or south-by-southwest or
sort of these different brands or
communities it's in a
multitrillion-dollar category got it and
I guess as part of creating that you
mentioned multiple players do you feel
like there will be specialization around
different use cases or do you feel like
you guys can build kind of a
foundational layer and then as you
described you'll get kind of vertical
building by entrepreneurs around you
know role parties or journalists tokens
or whatever there yeah so I think what
we're seeing right now is we have such
significant mindshare that the different
players are reaching out but you can
really unbundle a lot of things that are
going to happen right so like right now
there's like roles like I was like a
one-stop-shop right so you're minting
particularly for that of currency right
now but you know the next year people
may want this you know Chipotle style
minting process in a fast casual way I
mean what may want a minute token for my
birthday party on Saturday or you know
my relationship or doesn't anything
anything like this so you'll see
different minting products you'll see
this as you said sort of break into
categories I think those will be owned
by people in those communities so what
will happen is someone that knows a lot
of people and events will contact a
blockchain first company like roll
integrate it and then serve on board
those types of people so yeah you will
see segmentation
I think roles position in that to sort
of mass audience is really how it moves
from one platform to another right so if
you onboard Fat Boy slim on this DJ
platform he may also be interested in
streaming on Twitch we may create a
time-released bot that releases let's
say Fat Boy based on sort of how long
the streams are may also want to send it
on Twitter integrated into a Shopify
these are all part of the world that
role exists and moving social money from
one place to another so we've talked a
lot about people who all consider the
edge cases in terms of general society
right so these are people with smaller
communities things like that obviously
the largest networks in the world are
the Facebook's the Twitter's of the
world what is your thought process of
around do we've seen Facebook try to
create a currency that doesn't really
kind of correlate here that they went
more after what I can so I can
nation-state type currency twitter has
obviously a CEO and Founder who is very
bullish on Bitcoin as a currency do you
feel like this type of social money is
targeted at a different type of audience
then let's say the Facebook's and
Twitter's or do you see a world where
maybe whether it's them or other large
networks
maybe twitch or whoever says hey look we
actually want to create a twitch coin
right a Twitter coin and can use what
you guys are building to do that yeah I
think the real
frem asur sort of why why we're
personally fascinated by a role as it
flips the entire thesis of social on its
head right Chris Dixon from Andreessen
writes a little bit about this like has
a platform develops it just ends up
competing with its users in sort of
cannibalizing a lot of the activity that
happens and you saw that was sort of
Instagram getting rid of likes and sort
of a sort of a few other things like
that and flipping that thesis on its
head and allowing individuals to be the
network on top of these platforms is a
completely new idea so we've seen like
you seem like seem like can and props
and sort of different platforms create
tokens and if that continues to happen
right if there is a Facebook coin and a
snapchat coin one isn't going to adopt
the other right so Facebook isn't gonna
want to use snapchat coin and Twitter
isn't gonna want to use you know
Facebook coin but everyone's gonna want
to use Kim's coin Instagram is gonna
want to use it snapchats gonna want to
use it so imagine the top 1,000
influential people on the web having
their own currency this just becomes the
way of operating and sort of sort of
filters down so I think that's the real
play here instead of sort of a platform
creating their own their own currency
and yeah I think that that's sort of
it's sort of what we're after right now
what does that user experience look like
right so if pretty much every network
I'm a part of every community I'm a part
of every person that I kind of subscribe
to if everyone has their own currency
like how do I as a user manage all of
that how do I kind of think through that
does it become overwhelming to me what's
kind of thoughts there yeah so right now
you can kind of think about it as you
know thesis is like everyone that you
know can create a YouTube channel will
create a YouTube channel so everyone
that you know wants to create a currency
will and it'll be somewhat similar to
that it'll be somewhat similar to the
people that you follow the the YouTube
channels that you go to you may hold
you know 400 different currencies but
you may only actively engage and you
know let's say 20 what's become
fascinating is people see social money
as a primitive so this is starting to
grow in a sense and the question becomes
like what do you build on top of the
social money primitive and a lot of
people are really excited about the
concept of curation how can you imagine
how can you reimagine Twitter in this
version where the sort of boards are
different people's currencies and so
once you start playing around you know
reinventing social with this new type of
money you get these really unique ideas
of sort of how to play an engaging value
and I think that kind of changes who
wins and sort of how they win but
generally yeah the process and how you
associate with these currencies will be
very similar to how you associated with
the content around that individual yeah
it's super interesting and I guess if
let's say five to ten years from now
this is unsuccessful meaning social
money does not become a thing what would
you say is the number one reason today
that you could see that happening like
what's the biggest risk in terms of this
being unsuccessful moving forward it's
just an overall industry trend of social
money yeah so I would say right now I'd
say in the next few years I think what
we're gonna see is overwhelming
developer interest I think one knack
people have in on this space is sort of
blockchain in general is it's almost the
same almost a knitting circle of the
same like twenty thousand people talking
to each other about the same topics
you're not really seeing a lot of new
energy come in almost the same protocols
are kind of using each other in sort of
different ways if they're if developers
support developer demands sort of
increases in this category and massive
platforms are starting to utilize this
primitive of social money
I think everyone wins right more people
using compound more people are using you
know swap etc each bringing in sort of
new people new tokens new ideas so I
think one thing that would stop that is
sort of this
latent developer demand overtime luckily
we're seeing that now but if the people
who run massive platforms for some
reason don't want to integrate these
sorts of ideas or be able to have their
communities mint tokens yeah you could
see sort of a stagnation and yeah we're
not seeing that now but anything we do
see that in the future probably shift
figure out why and to reassess how to
get people excited and then talk to me
about the technology stack in terms of
all this right now is being built on top
of aetherium
from what I understand do you see that
being the long-term strategy do you
think that there's the possibility other
things will pop up that can kind of
replace that foundational blockchain how
do you think about technology stack and
the theory immerse other things yeah so
if that's a really special place in in
people's hearts right now it's for the
largest largest developer community and
I think it may have surpassed Bitcoin
that I'm not sure about that but you
know we're we're gonna go we're
basically the developer excitement is so
we're sort of at heart we're sort of
blockchain agnostic but you know we we
do love aetherium as sort of our kind of
introduction to sort of these types of
applications but it's you know it's
somewhat plausible that another block
and sort of comes in and does this but
the idea of role sort of porting that
value from one blockchain to another
becomes feasible right there's nothing
then effectively like ties roll forever
to atheria yeah we're just going to
continue to build because they have the
most primitives no one needs to rebuild
a unit swap or a compound or sort of any
of these things and we're really excited
about you know how things are going it
this could be some interesting things
with sort of a youth to and later to
scaling and you know we may adopt some
of those but in the future I gotta ask
does eath to ever happen well you know
that that's a really good question
luckily how roll works well works in a
semi custodial fashion so there's
thousands of people that are sending
money back and forth every day using
roll on sort of internally
and they use these links to blast them
out to masses amounts of people all of
those things are sort of off chain so
sort of go back to sort of rolls us I
mean custodial wallet there so for us we
really don't necessarily need eath to to
come out we would love it to come out
deserve the enhance what's going on with
us but yeah III think it's feasible now
that it comes out in the next sort of
eighty or four years awesome
what's the one thing that has surprised
you since you started roll
Oh hip-hop culture is trying to embrace
blockchain and in interesting ways so we
just did this podcast with with ja Rule
which was was fascinating as an awesome
guy learned about his background from
Def Jam but the conversation really
turned into something really special
because we saw a lot of commonalities
between blockchain and hip-hop right
they both started in these this is one
place right hip hop in the Bronx 1973
and you know Bitcoin blockchain with the
Bitcoin white paper and you know
somewhat centralized and they both sort
of spread out sort of became
decentralized over time to where anyone
could sort of utilize the technology and
so the idea of the thesis of that like
interview is like is blockchain the next
hip hop and if so like what is the Def
Jam moment where you know the Beastie
Boys of blockchain comes and the Run DMC
where all of a sudden hundreds of
millions of people are using it and so
using a lot of cultural figures that are
you really wouldn't suspect it but I
kind of talked to them behind the scenes
and they're there in this category where
they're super excited about blockchain
they just haven't found a reason to dive
in and we're seeing if you literally
brand a token after their presence it's
something that they're excited about so
those conversations are are super
exciting I wouldn't expect an audience
like that to embrace role look it's uh
it's a thing I think I said this to a
Ben baller once when you can applaud
cast I told him that uh he's a disrupter
he's an entrepreneur right he has a
think of himself that way but that's why
he's done his whole life is he's built
things right and he's been innovative
and so I think that a lot of folks
especially you know kind of the people
that you and I probably look up to is
like the hip-hop legends
kind of from the 80s and 90s like that's
really what they did right they had no
other choice they had to innovate and
build and so it's kind of cool to see
that they have an interest in a more
technology driven stuff we've seen from
professional athletes and all that but
I've seen it from kind of the music side
is is surprising yeah another thing I'm
excited about is just our investor basis
is pretty diverse in terms of where they
come from so
[Music]
there's folks that you know we're their
first blockchain that there's folks who
you know their only other bet is
coinbase so Moses Gary Vaynerchuk and
instead of his brother AJ they've been
super-supportive seeking a long-term
vision their Spencer Dinwiddie he's
great another investor been on the show
a few times Arthur Hays you know sort of
name synonymous with sort of Bitcoin
derivatives built a massive business
thinks this can be a massive business as
well all the way to just you know
traditional investors as well Silicon
Valley VC firms so having that sort of
evidence were very investor basis is
pretty helpful as well that makes sense
shout out the Spencer he's always gotta
he's always got a spot in my heart okay
awesome before I wrap up I ask the same
two questions first one is what is the
most important book that you've ever
read who you know what and you're gonna
ask that
I have several answers but I guess I'll
go with the top of mind answer it's
really hard to fire people it's really
hard to have serious conversations with
people whether it's at a founder level
or a company level or sort of any and
anything's with concrete are difficult
like that and there's a massively
successful book I'm just saying this
because I imagine people have rattled
off the same sort of top entrepreneur
book so my name or obscure one so this
book is called Crucial Conversations
I can look it up on Amazon literally
tells you how to start you know go
through the messy middle and sort of and
all these very serious conversations
that you need to have in a business
context after you read that you just
feel like you have the armor to deal
with any of the crazy nonsense let's say
your company or firm scales like 50 75
people thought of nonsense going on at
all times
reading that book you'll just feel
prepared for all these instances so
crucial conversations would be my bad I
love it a less serious question aliens
believer or non-believer
oh my god I've never been on record here
yeah you on Joe Rogan did it did a
pretty interesting podcast with a few
few believers and I do have to say that
it is it is probably likely that a
extraterrestrial life is out there is
also probably likely that uh you know
perhaps we're in a simulation and these
are all theories and people talk about
probabilistically yes would you believe
that aliens are real or the simulation
is real which one do you believe more
we're getting a wacky territory here but
if I have to answer I would say that it
could be possible that extraterrestrial
life is running a simulation and we are
the reality TV of other areas and maybe
some of the sightings that people have
or sort of like the repair guys kind of
coming in and kind of just like fixing
the simulation and going back but um
yeah maybe maybe maybe that's the case
daily ins are just jealous that they
don't have social money that's one yeah
yeah you could ask me one question to
finish up what you got for me under what
circumstances would you meant pump I for
whatever reason I knew that's what
you're gonna ask me I want to see it
there's two things that I'm waiting for
one I want to see it used at scale in a
way that gives me that confidence it's a
good investment of time alright so the
time investment is the most important
thing to me and time I use as a proxy
the more that I sink time into it that
means the more that I'm asking the
community and audience to trust me that
this is real this is gonna work it's
gonna be sustainable etc and in this
case when it comes to investing
like guns blazing love to be you know
the first or very early to do things
when it comes to the content stuff I'm
actually a very late to the game on a
lot of things it's like I don't even
have a tick-tock for example right and
some of it's by design of like I really
got to be convinced something's worth it
because I know that once I decided to do
something like it is a multi-year things
like that one of the things I talk when
it wants to create content is like hey
when you start are you signing up for
five years or ten years oh I didn't
realize that I can do it for the week
it's like now you like this is this a
multi-year thing so I think that's one
and the second thing is I don't think
that I understand yet what I would do
with it and that's on me of like I just
haven't critically thought enough about
like hey if I had this like what would I
do with it
frankly I probably would like joke
around on Twitter right which maybe
maybe that is a good use case I I just
don't know but I would have to think
really deeply about like if I'm going to
do it how do you do it and I think part
of I always go back to this one
principle when I worked at Facebook
there's a saying intro that was always
deliver more value than you extract
right or deliver more value than you
deliver or than you take and in this
case a lot of the use cases that I see
it's probably an equal value transfer
right it's like I'm getting as much
value as I'm giving and so I would have
to just think more critically about how
do you actually use this in a way where
the community people or the users get
more value than I'm actually getting you
will be helpful to me help thinking
through that but but also I think I just
gotta sit and critically think about it
and then once I know that and I see kind
of you know one or two examples of it
being used at scale you'll get me got it
yeah okay make sounds just right I see
your wheel spinning you're trying to
think of how you can sell me as soon as
we get off the call well no just
hypothetically I think you were on our
you were on our last year and they're
like our top 10 and people who wanted to
to grab the yeah listen
Never Say Never no of course all right
man listen I really appreciate you
taking the time to do this I will where
do you want people to go where can we
send them to check out you and roll on
the Internet
yeah yeah so check us out at WWE I will
calm there's 10,000 people using social
money right now you can sign up for our
beta we're gonna open that up to the
general public soon you can follow us on
twitter at at tri roll HQ shoot us to DM
or just say hi i'm at bradley underscore
miles underscore if you want to say hi
as well and yeah that's about it
awesome man well listen thank you so
much for doing this and what do to get
in the future cool man yeah this was
great thanks for your time